[Music]
I'm a city boy I'm from New York never
seeing in a cow or anything like that
hanging out with EMU it's pretty cool I
don't probably won't have an opportunity
like that and rest of my life
[Music]
we are at the Monroe County Sheriff's
Office animal farms on the grounds of
the detention center we have the
capacity to have 700 inmates in all
three of our Jail facilities this is the
main jail and we're the only facility of
this kind in the country that has a
exotic theory at a jail
[Music]
it started out with just farm animals
and now I have exotic animals of all
varieties kinkajous are from the
rainforests of Central and South America
that's the bird we call the I love you
bird and he is such a camera hog we only
take in animals that have been abandoned
abused confiscated or donated hi Tucker
we don't purchase any of the animals and
they're here for their life this is a
forever home for them I've been here
just for a year you know and these guys
are doing a life sentence I'm oh alright
Kramer gonna wake you up pretty girl
today I have four inmates every day they
come down here to feed water and clean
and then to spend time with the animals
what's going on buddy you're gonna get
out pretty soon
mandatory rec the farm is one of the
jobs in this facility that you could
actually be outside all day at number
got to hit the rack with a bunch of rare
cool animals like Kramer here he's got
the little curl on the top of his head
that's why we call Kramer this is he or
he he was uh he was saved from a
slaughterhouse and he's a lot better off
do you think working with the animals
helps the inmates with their
rehabilitation I've seen a lot of very
positive changes I've seen people that
come down here and are completely scared
of animals and by the end of their time
here at any of them bring their families
back to actually show them what they
were doing when they were incarcerated
I'm so happy to be out here when I first
came he was like not even this big tiny
and now look at you
[Music]
we don't go ahead and get situated this
is the finance program and we always
like to see new faces when you come to
Wall Street financial literacy class
you're gonna see people with tattoos and
dreads and just people you normally
wouldn't expect to see learn and finance
you're gonna see people of all different
backgrounds looking for hope he makes it
universal if I tell you I'll give you
250 bucks but I want you to pay me back
50 dollars in interest what you're gonna
say you're gonna say what and why you're
gonna say no they called me Wall Street
because I teach all the financial
classes here at San Quentin and I've
been teaching financial education for
about 10 years now I am in prison for
participating in a robbery murder and I
was sentenced to 54 years to life in
prison for that crime and I've been
incarcerated in that for 22 years these
are the stocks that I picked the
MasterCard
I got 89 they're at 200 Wall Street came
to prison they illiterate he doesn't
have a college education to this day he
only has a GED and yet this guy is
successfully trading from prison my
cellie who had come from juvenile hall
with me he would read the sports page to
me but man go get it and I read it I
grab the paper and I was like I got it
when I turned around on order guy said
hey man you play the stock market and
I've realized that I picked up the
business section instead of sports page
sounds like God man and I asked him what
the stock market was and he told me he
said that's the place where white folks
keep all the money and and that's when I
really first discovered the stock market
so I started teaching myself how to read
family friends on the outside opened up
online brokers accounts and I basically
told him what the buying when to buy and
when to sell and I mean I was just
simply Brazil was really just that easy
this is the finance program but I don't
teach about finance
I teach financial empowerment emotional
literacy that's what I teach so I think
financial education is important for car
serated people giving it the crimes that
are committed or financially motivated
and driven when I learned about
financial education myself I thought
that would be something that other men
and my same situation could benefit from
and so now the program teaches
incarcerated men how to better manage
their emotions and relations to their
financial standing so you gotta weigh
your strategies when you're talking
about giving you some room to start
saving money when you're traumatized you
do a lot of things you don't know why
you're doing them and that happens with
Finance too I suffered a lot of trauma
in my life and my trauma like culminated
in me murdering a man so while this is
very important to me because I do need
to manage my money and manage my life
what's most important is that I'm
managing my emotional responsibilities
because the last time I didn't do that a
man lost his life I don't think you can
have full rehabilitation without
financial education I can make amends
for the crimes that I've done I can even
stop doing the things that I've done but
I think for people who were criminals
when you empower those people and they
know that they don't have to commit
crime like I did when I learned that I
have to commit crime it was like wow
like I can really make something my life
and I have to be a criminal
I would say a bond between the inmate
and the horse is one of the most
important things that they learn when
they actually start to bond to that
horse they will become better trainers
they will become better people I think
that's good that they feel that much
pride in their horses it's good to have
pride in something especially in prison
[Music]
that goes right up behind his ears a
little bit with with that rope now when
that gets up there in my job
doing pretty good my name is Hank curry
I'm the head horse trainer here at the
Northern Nevada Correctional Center I've
been here 15 years now and then I'm in
charge of about 20 to 25 inmates
we're taking a completely wild horse and
trying to domesticate them get them
where they're a gentle usable horse the
inmates put in applications to come to
work out here according to their
behavior in prison we review all of that
and try to decide whether or not they
could possibly become horse trainers to
start out with we take a totally wild
horse and I have my guys actually put
them in a round drill we don't allow
them to rope them or anything else they
have to actually make contact with their
hands most of the inmates that may be
ridden a horse once or twice in their
life so it takes a lot of guts and it
takes a lot of determination this guy
right here didn't want nothing to do
with me and now he's you know my little
buddy and he follows me everywhere I go
it's just a moment where you bond you
know and you become you know like best
friends this guy only did it within the
last few weeks it's pretty amazing I
mean I'm not doing time until I go back
to him you know and that's when the
clock starts for me as far as realizing
where I'm at when I'm out here I'm free
in the last few years we've developed a
lot of horses that have been used by the
Fish and Game ordinance the Forestry
Service
the Sheriff's Department actually has a
amount of group and those were horses
trained by this program I think that you
know this job is kind of inspirational
it's not like regular prison where
everybody's running around being
foul-mouthed you know being a tough guy
and everything else doesn't work out
here horses don't care who you are how
big or how tough you are
they will equalize the playing field if
you want to play tough I see a great
deal of change in all these guys they
seem to mature they're functioning they
know how to work you know how to hold a
job so often it's it's changed their
lives
you
playing Hamlet has helped me ask
questions of myself that usually I we
buried deep inside I never thought I'd
do anything like this to be or not to be
that is the question my name is Leslie
career I'm the founding managing
director of Marin Shakespeare Company
the methodology of our program is
inspired by drama therapy
it creates laughter in the room and it
breaks down barriers between races and
ages and groups it's very beautiful and
we've seen a lot of transformation most
of the men in the group don't have any
theater experience and haven't studied
Shakespeare before so when we start
talking about the plays and the
characters they're just bringing their
own personal life experience to the
conversation when I first came in I
thought I would never act again I
attended college back in Nebraska in
1968 and 69 I was a co major theater and
music when I came into prison there is
this certain demeanor that you have to
establish so in essence I'm acting on a
day-to-day basis just to survive to be
able to be up on that stage
letting the true Steve come through but
in the person of the character
that's the freedom I get or that's what
I hope comes out when I do Polonius
pastoral historical comic this role is
is so challenging that it makes me go
through the entire gamut of emotions
he's so conflicted that a man I must
have pulled from every facet of my life
I've been betrayed before I've had my
trust broken I've
I've done really horrible things to
people you know in a rage like Hamlet's
done well you may see the inmost part of
you Oh we'll have to murder me over the
years I've learned I have to give back
that I also have to own up and look at
what I did
realistically I'm hoping through other
things that I do my acting I can give
something back to society I've been able
to use all of my past experience and
kind of channel it into this character I
hope that playing my role helps the
other inmates here feel like they're
part of the story this doesn't just help
me escape this helps them escape too it
also helps me a gain a lot of empathy
for you know what other people are going
through it's uh tearing open old wounds
to try to embody this to bring the
character alive and bring other people
within the story it's it's difficult but
it's also really cathartic it helps
it helps me heal in this cruel world
draw thy breath in pain to tell my story
the rest silence
[Applause]
[Music]
we're in modern life can we be accepted
by others in all of our facets the
beautiful and the ugly the comfortable
and the uncomfortable how do we open
that Pandora's box and dance with it
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Evangeline and I am the puto
[Music]
butoh is an art form that was born in
Japan in the 1950s now it is a global
art form for me butoh is the dance of
darkness the dance of the subconscious I
think that body and mind and spirit are
completely connected when we access the
body through repetition there is a part
of the mind that surrenders and we begin
to access emotions
there is no erectus
butoh training is really really really
challenging to be pushed to the limit to
that extent and encouraged to have an
encounter with the self it's not an easy
endeavor but it's a particularly acute
challenge for people who are
incarcerated
I started that my working correctional
facilities with bruto in 2006 the
classes at Edgecombe are very powerful
they're also a process and in the
correctional facilities it's a very
volatile environment my agenda is to
start with a blank slate it's not my
place to judge them it's my place to
provide a space of self-acceptance for
them a place for rehabilitation
once they connect to the sense of
empowerment that's a very important
concept for people who are incarcerated
self-knowledge self power how can I be
in control of my of my body that is
essentially being controlled by the
states the ones that keep coming back
and repeat and believing the repetition
and start on a path of commitment
achieve great results it's dance from
the guts it's a dance from the soul it's
magic
[Music]